LIKE GROUNDHOG DAY. IT'S
EVERY DAY. IT'S AARON
RODGERS DAY BECAUSE THE
CONTINUED FOR NOW THE SEVENTH
DAY AND A COUPLE OF ITEMS
EMERGED TODAY. SHIREEN, LET'S
START WITH BOB,
AGAIN OF THE ATHLETIC WHEN
HE'S NOT TALKING TO IT ON THE
SCOUTS TO HARVEST NEGATIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT DRAFT PICKS,
HE'S GETTING SOME GOOD
INFORMATION ABOUT THE THINGS
AARON RODGERS MAY OR MAY NOT
BE DOING. AND ACCORDING TO
BEGIN, ROGERS, HAS MOCKED
GOODYKOONTZ TO HIS HORROR OF
CALLED HIM ON HIS PODCAST.
HEARST, WHICH I ACTUALLY LIKE
BETTER. HE HAS MOCKED
GOODYKOONTZ AND CALLED HIM,
JERRY KRAUSE, WHICH I WOULD
ASSUME IN THE GENERAL MANAGER
BEING CALLED SOMETHING THAT
CAN'T BE REPEATED IN ANY
SETTING EVEN SATELLITE OR
CABLE. SO WE HAVE THAT NEW
DEVELOPMENT AS WE LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE EXTENT TO WHICH
AARON RODGERS, REALLY DOESN'T
LIKE BRIAN GUDYKUNST.
HE REALLY, REALLY DOESN'T
LIKE BRIAN GOOGOOTZ. HE
DOESN'T LIKE YOU MIKE, HE
DOESN'T LIKE HIS FAMILY
DOESN'T SEEM TO LIKE ANYONE
BUT HE REALLY, REALLY DOESN'T
BUT HE REALLY REALLY DOESN'T
DOESN'T SEEM TO LIKE ANYONE
LIKE THE GRIND GOOD. YOU JUST
BUT HE REALLY REALLY DOESN'T
MADE THE LIST I DID AND IN
LIKE THE GRIND GOOD. YOU JUST
PRIVATE CARS BEEN ON THE
MADE THE LIST I DID AND IN
LIST AND SOMEHOW HE'S MANAGED
PRIVATE CARS BEEN ON THE
TO GET HIS WAY OFF THE LIST
LIST AND SOMEHOW HE'S MANAGED
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW HE QUITE
TO GET HIS WAY OFF THE LIST
DOES THAT. BUT BRIAN GOOD.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW HE QUITE
ACOUSTICS. PROBABLY FIRST ON
DOES THAT. BUT BRIAN GOOD.
THAT LIST RIGHT NOW. MIKE
ACOUSTICS. PROBABLY FIRST ON
BASED ON WHAT WE WHAT WE READ
THAT LIST RIGHT NOW. MIKE
AND HEARD TODAY,
BASED ON WHAT WE WHAT WE READ
IT REALLY IS AMAZING. HOW
AND HEARD TODAY,
THIS STUFF JUST KEEPS
IT REALLY IS AMAZING. HOW
CASCADING. IT KEEPS COMING
THIS STUFF JUST KEEPS
OUT AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE
CASCADING. IT KEEPS COMING
THE LEAKS ARE COMING FROM NOW
OUT AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE
I THINK EVERYTHING WAS COMING
THE LEAKS ARE COMING FROM NOW
FROM ROGERS OR HIS CAMP NOW.
I THINK EVERYTHING WAS COMING
COULD BE SELECTIVE LEAKS MADE
FROM ROGERS OR HIS CAMP NOW.
BY THE TEAM MADE BY PEOPLE
COULD BE SELECTIVE LEAKS MADE
WITH THE ORGANIZATION, WHO
BY THE TEAM MADE BY PEOPLE
HAPPY WITH THIS, OR JUST
WITH THE ORGANIZATION, WHO
TEAMMATES WHO HAVE HAD ENOUGH
HAPPY WITH THIS, OR JUST
OF IT, BUT IT MAY NOT BE
TEAMMATES WHO HAVE HAD ENOUGH
ROGERS NOW, AND I DON'T KNOW
OF IT, BUT IT MAY NOT BE
THAT IT HELPS ROGERS TO LEAK
ROGERS NOW, AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT, HE MOCKS GUDYKUNST AND
THAT IT HELPS ROGERS TO LEAK
CALLS HIM. JERRY KRAUSE, I
THAT, HE MOCKS GUDYKUNST AND
DON'T KNOW THAT. THAT'S A
CALLS HIM. JERRY KRAUSE, I
GOOD LOOK AND I DON'T KNOW,
DON'T KNOW THAT. THAT'S A
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING
GOOD LOOK AND I DON'T KNOW,
THAT'S GOING TO CAUSE
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING
PACKERS FANS TO FEEL GOOD
THAT'S GOING TO CAUSE
AARON.
PACKERS FANS TO FEEL GOOD
OTHERS, AND THAT LEADS TO THE
AARON.
OTHER REPORT TODAY FOR MIGHT
OTHERS, AND THAT LEADS TO THE
GAROFOLO ABOUT A FILM MEDIA.
OTHER REPORT TODAY FOR MIGHT
THAT FAVRE ACTUALLY WARNED
GAROFOLO ABOUT A FILM MEDIA.
PROSPECTIVE FREE AGENTS
THAT FAVRE ACTUALLY WARNED
PACKERS PLAYERS WHO WERE DUE
PROSPECTIVE FREE AGENTS
TO BECOME FREE AGENTS. AARON
PACKERS PLAYERS WHO WERE DUE
RODGERS, SAID THAT, THAT
TO BECOME FREE AGENTS. AARON
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE THERE
RODGERS, SAID THAT, THAT
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE THERE
WHETHER IT'S DAVID BAKHTIARI,
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO
WHO STAYED COREY LINSLEY?
WHETHER IT'S DAVID BAKHTIARI,
WHO LEFT AARON JONES, WHO
WHO STAYED COREY LINSLEY?
STAYED ANY OF THE PERSPECTIVE,
WHO LEFT AARON JONES, WHO
AARON. RODGERS WAS TELLING
STAYED ANY OF THE PERSPECTIVE,
THEM ACCORDING TO THEIR APOLO.
AARON. RODGERS WAS TELLING
THAT HE'S NOT GOING TO BE
THEM ACCORDING TO THEIR APOLO.
THERE. TO ME THE SHIREEN THAT
THAT HE'S NOT GOING TO BE
WAS STUNNING.
THERE. TO ME THE SHIREEN THAT
DISMANTLING. YOUR TEAM ARE
WAS STUNNING.
TRYING TO. IT SEEMS LIKE NOW
DISMANTLING. YOUR TEAM ARE
THEY GOT SOME OF THOSE GUYS
TRYING TO. IT SEEMS LIKE NOW
TO STAY BUT WE KNOW THAT
THEY GOT SOME OF THOSE GUYS
MONEY TALKS AND AND THE
TO STAY BUT WE KNOW THAT
PACKERS GAVE HIM A LOT OF
MONEY TALKS AND AND THE
MONEY TO GET THEM TO STAY.
PACKERS GAVE HIM A LOT OF
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
MONEY TO GET THEM TO STAY.
THAT. BUT YEAH, IT'S STUNNING
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT YOU WOULD TELL
THAT. BUT YEAH, IT'S STUNNING
TEAMMATES HEY I'M NOT GOING
THAT YOU WOULD TELL
TO BE THERE. THAT'S TEAM.
TEAMMATES HEY I'M NOT GOING
BASICALLY, WHAT YOU'RE
TO BE THERE. THAT'S TEAM.
SAYING IS THIS TEAM MAY BE IN
BASICALLY, WHAT YOU'RE
SORT OF A REBUILD MOLD WITH
SAYING IS THIS TEAM MAY BE IN
UNPROVEN AT THIS POINT O'S
SORT OF A REBUILD MOLD WITH
BECAUSE I'M THE GUY TO LEAD
UNPROVEN AT THIS POINT O'S
SUPER BOWL AND I MAY NOT BE
BECAUSE I'M THE GUY TO LEAD
DON'T BE IN THERE. SO THIS
SUPER BOWL AND I MAY NOT BE
WAS STUNNING. MIKE, NO
DON'T BE IN THERE. SO THIS
QUESTION.
WAS STUNNING. MIKE, NO
AND LOOK.
I'M TRYING TO BE SO OBJECTIVE
ON THIS THAT I'M WORRIED
ABOUT THINGS THAT I PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T WORRY ABOUT BEING
PACKERS FANS CAN JUDGES FOR
THEMSELVES. I AM NOT TRYING
TO STIR THE POT HERE. I
ALWAYS STIR THE POT.
GENERALLY IF STIRRING THE POT
IS THE NATURAL BYPRODUCT OF
BEING HONEST ABOUT WHAT, I
SEE WHAT I SEE HERE AND I
THINK I WOULD BELIEVE THIS
ANY QUARTERBACK UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE REGARDLESS OF
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT ME IN THE
PAST REGARDLESS OF HOW HE
FEELS ABOUT ME, REGARDLESS
I'VE CRITICIZED HIM AND I'VE
PRAISED
HIM AS A PLAYER, JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO, I WAS SAYING THEY
SHOULD HIRE HIM ON JEOPARDY
THAT HE WOULD BE GREAT AND HE
WAS GREAT AS THE HOST I AM
CAPABLE OF BEING OBJECTIVE.
AND IN THIS SPECIFIC INSTANCE,
MY OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS IS, IF
I'M A PACKERS FAN, I AM
UPSET WITH THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
AARON RODGERS WAS ACTIVELY
UNDERMINING. THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE TEAM TELLING
GUYS DON'T BOTHER TO RE-SIGN
BASICALLY. EVEN THOUGH THAT
EXACT LANGUAGE. LOOK, WHAT
YOU SHOULD DO AT A MINIMUM
SAY NOTHING. NOTHING, RIGHT?
RIGHT GUYS, THINKING ABOUT
RESIGNING. I YOU KNOW, I
I'LL BE HERE NEXT YEAR. DON'T
SAY ANYTHING. DON'T SAY
ANYTHING. DON'T TRY TO
SABOTAGE WITH THE TEAMS
TRYING TO DO AND HOLDING
OTHER PLAYERS ON THE ROSTER.
SAME THING THAT I FELT ABOUT
LAUNCHING THIS CRUSADE
AGAINST THE PACKERS ON DRAFT,
IT DISTRACTING THE FRONT
OFFICE DISTRACTING BRIAN
GUDYKUNST AT A TIME WHEN HE
SHOULD BE COMPLETELY AND
TOTALLY FOCUSED AS FOCUSED AS
ALL OF THE GENERAL MANAGERS
ARE ON THE THREE DAYS OF THE
DRAFT TRADE UP, TRADE DOWN.
WHO DO I PICK? WHAT DO I DO?
HOW DO WE READ OUR BOARD? HOW
DO WE MAKE THESE DECISIONS IN
A COMPRESSED TIME FRAME? YOU
DON'T NEED THAT CRAP.
HOVERING OVER YOUR HEAD.
IF I'M A PACKERS FAN, I'M
GETTING MORE AND MORE PISSED
OFF AT AARON RODGERS SHIREEN
YEAH, AND I HEARD LAST NIGHT,
THE BREWERS GAME, THERE WAS A
SMATTERING OF BOOS WHEN THEY
SHOWED AARON RODGERS EVEN ON
THE SCHOOL ON THE VIDEO BOARD
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT. BUT
THIS IS ONLY GOING TO GROW
FOR PACKERS FANS, YOU KNOW.
AND I THINK AARON RODGERS WAS
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. I
THINK HE WANTED HIS CAKE AND
EAT IT TOO. HE WANTS TO LEAVE
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT. I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON THAT, PACKERS FANS
CAN EVEN SEE THAT. NOW,
AARON RODGERS WANTS TO LEAVE
THIS TEAM. HE DOESN'T WANT TO
BE BACK, BUT HOW DOES HE DO
IT GRACEFULLY? AND I THINK
IT'S PAST
SET POINT AT THIS POINT. MIKE,
I THINK THERE'S NO GRACEFUL
LEAVING FOR AARON RODGERS. HE
KEEPS COMING OUT EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND IT'S PROBABLY GOING
TO CONTINUE TO COME OUT AND
IT JUST MAKES AARON RODGERS
LOOK WORSE AND WORSE AND
WORSE AS HE PLANS HIS EXIT
OUT OF GREEN BAY. AND
SOMETHING YOU POINTED OUT
YESTERDAY WHEN YOU FIRST
STARTED THIS, AFTER THEY LOST
TO THE BUCCANEERS IN THE NFC
CHAMPIONSHIP AND WE ALL
REACTED TO IT WHEN HE MADE
THE COMMENT SUGGESTING THAT
HIS OWN FUTURE, IS UNCERTAIN,
TWO DAYS LATER, HE CLEARED IT
ALL UP BEFORE, IT COULD
BECOME A THING. NOW IT
CONTINUES TO DOMINATE THE
NOW, IF YOU WANT TO PUT WAIT
IN THE TOOTHPASTE HOLDER. NOW
IS THE TIME? WELL, IT'S
ALREADY TOO LATE. IT'S
ALREADY TOO LATE. THAT'S THE
THING. EVEN IF HE WOULD TRY
NOW AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS,
HE'S TOLD AT LEAST ONE
TEAMMATE. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE BIG DEAL IS. WELL, OKAY,
DON'T THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
WITH YOU BECAUSE IT IS A BIG
DEAL, YOU HELPED MAKE IT A
BIG DEAL, YOUR CAP HELP MAKE
IT A BIG DEAL AND THERE'S
BEEN NOTHING TO UNMAKE IT. A
BOTTOM LINE IS HE TALKED TO
MIKE TIRICO ON SATURDAY.
GO ON CAMERA. THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S HIS PREROGATIVE. WE
WENT ON CAMERA WITH TWIN
SPIRES BUT DIDN'T TALK ABOUT
THE PACKERS, BUT HE WOULDN'T
TALK ON CAMERA WITH NBC ABOUT
THE PACKERS, BUT HE SAID TO
TIRICO ON THE RECORD ENOUGH
MAKE TIRICO BELIEVE AND
COMMUNICATE THAT. THERE'S A
FISSURE. THERE'S A CHASM
BETWEEN ROGERS IN THE FRONT
OFFICE AND HE EXPRESSED
REGRET ROGERS, DID OR
DISAPPOINTMENT THAT IT CAME
OUT, BUT IT'S OUT. HE DIDN'T
SAY, IT DOESN'T EXIST. HE
SIMPLY EXPRESSED REGRET THAT
IT CAME OUT.
HOW BIG OF A DEAL IS THIS
MIC? WELL, AN MVP HAS NEVER
LEFT THE TEAM THE YEAR AFTER
HE WON THE MVP AWARD AND GONE
ON TO ANOTHER TEAM. WE'VE HAD
TO RETIRE THE YEAR AFTER THEY
WON THE AWARD, BUT NEVER AN
MVP. GO TO A DIFFERENT TEAM.
SO THAT'S HOW BIG THIS IS.
THIS IS HUGE. AND YOU COULD
SQUASH THIS IF YOU WANTED IF
AARON RODGERS WANTED THIS TO
END. NOW, IT SAYS HEY I'M
HAPPY WITH THE PACKARD. GO ON
THE PAT MCAFEE SHOW. I'M
HAPPY WITH THE PACKERS. I'M
COMING BACK, I'M GOING TO
IN ANOTHER MVP AWARD TRY TO
WIN THE SUPER BOWL BLAH BLAH
BLAH. HE HASN'T DONE THAT. SO
WE GET WHERE ARE ROGERS. IS
HIS SILENCE. HE TELLS US
WHERE HE IS AND THE FACT IS
HE WANTS OUT OF GREEN BAY
THAT MUCH HAS BECOME
PAINFULLY. OBVIOUS TO PACKERS
FANS AS WELL. YEAH. AND WITH
EACH PASSING HOUR, IT'S
BECOMING HARDER AND HARDER
FOR HIM TO UNDO THIS
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE
WHEN YOU'RE REALLY
SMART, YOU GET THE BENEFIT OF
THE DOUBT THAT EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE IS CALCULATED AND
STRATEGIC AND IF IT
ISN'T, THEN HE'S NOT AS SMART.
AS WE ALL THINK. BRETT FAVRE
WAS ON RADIO TODAY WITH
WILL T AND TAU ESPN RADIO.
HERE'S FAVRE, TALKING ABOUT A
WITH AARON RODGERS REGARDING
THE SITUATION.
THEY WERE WILLING TO TRADE
ME. IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
PACKERS NOW ARE NOT WILLING
RAID AARON,
YOU KNOW, IT'S A TUG-OF-WAR
SO IT'S SIMILAR BUT BUT ALSO
VERY DIFFERENT THAN MY
SITUATION. I JUST SENT ARE IN
A MESSAGE AND SAID, HEY AM I
GOING TO SEE YOU PLAYING FOR
KIND OF JOKING AND R? JUST
HE SENT BACK. HEY BUDDY I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN AND I AM ALSO IN
THAT TEXT. I JUST SAID HEY I
HOPE EVERYTHING'S OKAY YOU
KNOW.
FROM PEOPLE. ASK ME WHAT'S ES
THE DEAL AND HE SAID, HEY
THANKS FOR CHECKING ON ME.
I'LL TOUCH BASE WITH YOU.
AFTER ALL, THIS IS OVER.
AFTER ALL, THIS IS OVER,
WHICH IMPLIES THERE IS
SOMETHING THERE THAT NEEDS TO
BE OVER AND WE'LL BE OVER
AND WE'LL BE OVER EVENTUALLY.
IT'S NOT THIS IS NO BIG DEAL.
IT'S NOT DON'T BELIEVE WHAT
YOU READ AT PRO FOOTBALL TALK.
DON'T WASTE YOUR TIME.
READING THAT CRAP, HE COULD
RESPONSE TO THE BRETT FAVRE,
TEXT MESSAGE. AND THE
WAS I'LL CHECK IN WITH YOU
WHEN THIS IS ALL OVER FURTHER.
CONFIRMING THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THERE AND LOOK,
HE'S NOT GOING TO PLAY FOR
THE SAINTS BECAUSE THE
PACKERS ARE GOING TO TRADE
HIM TO THE SAINTS. THE SAINTS
DON'T NEED HIM. THE SAINTS
CAN'T AFFORD HIM.
THE PACKERS DON'T WANT HIM IN
THE CONFERENCE, THAT DOESN'T
MEAN HE'S NOT GOING TO BE
TRADED AND THAT'S A SEPARATE
ISSUE ALTOGETHER. BUT CLEARLY,
FAR OF HIS FURTHER CONFIRMED
BY TALKING DIRECTLY TO
ROGERS, THERE'S SOMETHING
THERE.
THERE IS SOMETHING. THEY'RE
IN, IT'S IRREPARABLE AT THIS
POINT AND IT.
IT STARTED BACK. WE ALL KNOW
WITH THE JORDAN LOVE
SELECTION AND I DON'T THINK
THEY DID A GOOD JOB OF
COMMUNICATED WITH AARON
RODGERS ABOUT WHAT THEY
INTENDED TO DO THAT. THEY
WERE GOING TO TRADE UP THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO DRAFT A
QUARTERBACK AND THEY PASSED
ON A TALENTED GROUP OF
RECEIVERS BY DOING THAT. NOW
IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR GRAPH
THIS YEAR, THEY'VE HELPED
THEIR TEAM. THEY HAD A REALLY
GOOD DRAFT BY ALL ACCOUNTS,
AARON RODGERS MAY NOT BE
THERE THIS YEAR TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PLAYERS THAT
THE PACKERS HAVE GIVEN THEM
IN THAT DRAFT. IT MAY BE
LOVES DRAFT TO USE THOSE.
PLAYERS TO TRY TO GO TO A
SUPER BOWL. GO WIN A SUPER
BOWL SO HE MAY LEAVE LEAVE
THERE WITH ONE SUPER BOWL AND
IT ALL STARTED WITH THE
DRAFTING OF JORDAN LOVE AND
IT JUST SEEMINGLY. MIKE HAS
GONE DOWNHILL FROM THERE, ROB.
DUMAS. GIVE ESPN HAS
REPORTED THAT THE PACKERS
THINK THE 49ERS AND THE
BRONCOS OF TAMPERED WITH
AARON RODGERS. AND I WOULD
SUSPECT, I DON'T THINK THE
AND I WOULD SUSPECT, I DON'T
THINK THE MOSQUE. HE
EXPLAINED IT THIS WAY, MY
GUESS WOULD BE, IT WAS
SOLICITED TAMPERING BY ROGERS.
CAMP TRYING TO
AN IRATE A TRADE MARKET
GETTING THE WORD OUT THAT
THERE'S REASON TO CALL
REMEMBER LAST WEEK, WHEN THE
49ERS MADE THAT CALL
WEDNESDAY NIGHT,
KYLE SHANAHAN TOLL RICH EISEN
EARLIER THIS WEEK. HE DIDN'T
WANT TO WAKE UP FRIDAY
MORNING AND FIND OUT THAT
AARON RODGERS HAD BEEN TRADED
TO SOMEONE ELSE. HE HAD
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THERE
WAS REASON TO CALL AND I
THINK THAT THERE WERE
PROVEN, THE PACKERS ARE GOING
TO CLAIM TAMPERING. THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE A SMOKING
GUN GM'S, FRONT OFFICE
EXECUTIVE COACHES. THEY
AREN'T STUPID ABOUT THIS AND
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE THE NFL
ARBITRARILY AND SELECTIVELY
ENFORCED, THE TAMPERING RULES
BUT I SUSPECT THAT ROGERS
IN MAKING PHONE CALLS, TRYING
GET CERTAIN TEAMS TO CONTACT
THE PACKERS. AND IF YOU DO
ANYTHING OTHER THAN HANG UP,
THE PHONE, IMMEDIATELY AND
REPORT THAT COMMUNICATION TO
THE PACKERS, YOU VIOLATED THE
TAMPERING RULES.
WELL, YOU GO BACK TO 2008
MIKE AND THE PACKERS ACCUSED.
THE VIKINGS OF THE EXACT
SAME THING WITH BRETT, FAVRE
AND NOTHING LED TO IT. SO, IT
IS SELECTIVE WHEN THE NFL
CHOOSES TO ENFORCE THESE,
YOU POINTED OUT THE JEREMY
MACLIN ONE WITH THE CHIEFS
TALKING TO MACKLIN, WHEN HE
WAS STILL UNDER CONTRACT WITH
THE EAGLES. I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY THE LAST TIME THAN
ANY TEAM SUFFERED
CONSEQUENCES FROM TAMPERING
WITH PLAYER. WE KNOW IT GOES
ON ALL THE TIME AND IT
PROBABLY DID HAPPEN IN THIS
CASE. NO QUESTION. NOW
WHETHER IT WAS ROGER'S CAMP
ROGERS, CAMP. HOWEVER, THAT
PROBABLY SOME COMMUNICATION
OTHERWISE, HOW WOULD THE
49ERS NO TO PICK UP THE
PHONE AND CALL ON WEDNESDAY
NIGHTS? A, A JUST IN CASE,
CONSIDERING TRADING AARON
RODGERS DOT DOT DOT. SO I DO
BELIEVE THERE WAS SOME
CONVERSATION THERE MIKE AND
YOU KNOW, EVEN THOUGH THE
PACKERS MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
PROVE THAT THERE WAS A
SMOKING GUN, THAT THERE WAS
SOME SORT OF COMMUNICATION.
THERE'S BEEN ENOUGH SAID,
PUBLICLY BY GM JOHN LYNCH AND
A SHANAHAN. I MENTIONED THE
COMMENT THAT HE MADE TO RICH
EISEN THE OTHER DAY. THAT
WOULD AT LEAST MAKE IT
PLAUSIBLE. IF THE PACKERS
WANTED TO MAKE TAMPERING
CHARGES AND HAVE AN
INVESTIGATION LAUNCHED AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S ALWAYS SMART
TO SAY, WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
PLAYERS WHO ARE UNDER
CONTRACT WITH OTHER TEAMS
PROBLEM, ALTOGETHER, SPEAKING